[Music]
North Korean leader Kim Jong-un has been
trying to build a new image for himself
he's gotten a new wardrobe
and lost some weight
he's also been showing emotion
[Applause]
while still being the commander-in-chief
who oversees epic missile launches he's
going for versatility North Korea's
propaganda strategy under Kim Jong-un
are modernization and transparency
the shift comes as the regime is facing
a lot of challenges at home North Korean
analysts say adapting the regime's
propaganda is one way to keep the
message under control
so We examined recent footage that shows
Kim's efforts to modernize what his
predecessors did as he redefines what it
means to be the leader of one of the
world's most isolated regimes
Kim Jong-un is the third leader of North
Korea after his father and grandfather
he took power in late 2011 when he was
believed to be just 27 years old Kim
Jong-un started off building his Public
Image modeled on his grandfather Rachel
Lee is a former North Korea analyst for
the U.S government who now works for a
website that provides analysis about the
regime
until recently Kim Jong-un had been
borrowing from his grandfather's
propaganda Playbook
the way he likes to give public speeches
when you see Kim Jong-un going out
visiting places or giving inspections
you see him mingling with people so when
people see him they're reminded of Kim
also but in recent years he's broken out
of that shell now and he's trying to
build his own brand and this rebranding
comes amid the country's mounting
economic problems as a result of ongoing
sanctions and the pandemic lockdown plus
there's been major flooding and crop
failures that have led to food shortages
estate runs South Korean Think Tank
estimates that the north needs more than
5 million tons of food annually the last
year it could have faced food shortages
of more than one million tons that food
deficit means an average North Korean is
getting around 450 calories fewer than
what's recommended by the United Nations
Lee says citizens won't believe the
regime if all these issues are covered
up so North Korea has really made an
effort to be more transparent to be
persuasive to the people and also to
make the content more interesting
to do that Kim's been attempting to
break the mold by trying new things
like in this highly edited video that
showcases the launch of what Pyongyang
described as a Next Generation
intercontinental ballistic missile
in walking out in front of a missile you
know that's something that you would see
maybe in a mission an impossible movie
this is a big departure from previous
weapons tests where Kim often watched
from inside a control room
and the event was announced by a news
anchor describing what happened
Lee says this kind of elaborate
production can drum up support for the
military even amid questions about the
regime's weapons capability
about a week after the launch South
Korean officials questioned whether the
ICBM was really new saying it appeared
to be just a dressed up version of a
predecessor
and this stylized video could also have
been produced to mollify the North
Korean public about a missile test in
mid-march that South Korea's military
said had failed they went out all the
way to make the video more special to
kind of bending over backwards right
overcompensating for what happened but
if they continue to do this then maybe
this is the beginning of a new trend
Pyongyang hasn't commented on the test
or the ICBM launch skepticism
what's also changing is the clothing and
Kim's various outfits are a stark
contrast to his father and grandfather
they normally stuck to a uniform whether
it was a suit and necktie or Mouse suits
which were popularized by communist
China's first leader
Kim has also allowed t-shirts that North
Korea experts say appeared to have his
face emblazoned on it like at this
concert last fall it's something that
you see all the Time in the West and
maybe it was somebody's idea to become
more modernized Lee says this type of
casual iconography would never have
happened during the regime under Kim's
father and grandfather because
propaganda has always portrayed the
leaders as sacred and Powerful Godlike
figures so this modernizing of content
marks a turning point and could come
from a desire for Kim to reach a younger
generation they're more knowledgeable
about the outside world a huge portion
of the population that has been exposed
to dramas and movies hence the need to
modernize content and it has to evolve
so that people keep tuning into National
Television another part of kin's
propaganda change more transparency
especially about the food shortage this
was also something that Kim's father had
to manage during his tenure at the time
there was no real acknowledgment of its
severity even though as many as one
million people in North Korea had died
North Korean State media used terms like
food shortages and food problem you
would see more watered-down account of
what was going on eventually the U.S and
United Nations stepped in to provide
food Aid and helped to bring the famine
to an end by the late 1990s
but fast forward some 20 years and Kim
Jong-un is going about it differently by
openly talking about the food situation
that the country faces today
this documentary called the great year
of victory in 2021 aired on state media
in February the narrator says the phrase
food crisis something that North Korea
analysts say has never been uttered
before in the country's propaganda
while Kim has said the country is
investing in agriculture and making
progress on the food shortage he's also
been physically showing citizens that he
understands their struggles
last June he appeared at a party meeting
looking considerably thinner and news of
his weight loss was widely reported on
state media
[Applause]
and also you see Kim Jong-un giving a
speech and he was in tears and he was
choking up as he talked about the
hardship that people had to go through
North Korea analysts say it's hard to
tell if this new propaganda style is
working and whether younger people are
relating to it more than earlier forms
ultimately propaganda is not about
getting anyone's approval the shaping
and controlling people's perception of
the leadership especially during
challenging times as Kim enters the
second decade of his rule
foreign